parabolic mirrors so this is a
particular shape Parabola shape and
these are used to focus signals so they
can be used in satellite dishes that's
why they have this shaped Parabola you
can use them in listening devices to
focus a weak sound signals using
Espionage and then amplify the signal
that you're getting it's used in torches
spotlights to focus the beam really cool
stuff and we're going to go through the
maths of it the geometry to see how that
focusing works like why does it have to
be a parabola shape to get this focusing
Behavior All right so big Parabola
something like that so let's say this is
X this is why my Parabola here is going
to be oh I've drawn it this way so it's
y squared equals 4 ax is the equation so
you might be used to it being y equals x
squared would be that way up because
I've rotated it so let's now take point
in our Parabola let's call this point p
and this is going to be a distance X on
the x-axis this is going to be at the
position a times t squared now a is
important because a here is controlling
how steep the parabola is so as we make
a bigger these sort of become steeper
closer and as we make a smaller these
become narrower so a just controls the
shape so we're covering all possible
parabolas by including it of course we
could just set it to one but let's be
General and then t as we increase and
decrease T we slide up and down the
x-axis now if this is at x equals a t
squared then we can work out the Y value
of this so if y squared is 4ax then I
think that's going to mean that y can be
plus or minus 2 a t and there's going to
be a minus 280 down here we're going to
focus on the plus point
so they're the two points on the
parabola when X is this satisfying that
equation now how a parabolic mirror
works is you have light sound coming in
and the parabolic shape acts to focus it
onto a single point so that's how you
get your TV signal you have all these
bits of the signal they get focused give
you a nice strong signal same for
listening devices torches whatever it
might be you can even use them to
collect sunlight and create a little bit
of heat a bit of fire here in the desert
for example I am going to claim that
this is going to go to a point on the
x-axis a0 so a distance of a inside
Parabola and again remember a just
controls the shape so obviously this
will move as the shape changes as you
would expect but it's definitely at y
values zero so it's on the x-axis so if
we're going to argue that this is the
case then what this is going to mean is
we're going to have a wave light wave
sound wave coming in horizontally and we
need it to bounce like this now we could
have another one say it was here like
this coming in horizontally heading here
and I'm claiming it's going to bounce to
that same point that's what we want
that's the whole purpose of the
parabolic mirror all these horizontal
beams coming in bouncing off that and
they all converge at the same point
amplifies your signal gives you your
heat to your light your sound whatever
you want so that's like where you'd put
maybe your sensor or your receiver
exactly that that's where your sensors
or or your uh your bulb in a torch so
because for a torch it bounces out this
way and then you get a nice perfect
horizontal beam so if you if you have a
torch you get like a focused beam oh
imagine what that might look like it's
quite a focused beam okay it sort of
expands a little bit but it's relatively
focused compared to like the light on
the ceiling or you know a studio light
that we have over here the light just
kind of goes everywhere it's not in a
focused beam because the studio light is
just a load of bulbs putting in all
directions here what we're doing is the
bulb is pinging everything so it comes
out in this focused beam it's how
spotlights work where's the parabola
there so the parabola
it's going to be inside a bit just
inside there yeah quite hard to tell
it's exactly a parabola but if you
measured it I can guarantee you it would
be it's having the same the same effect
Okay so
if we're going to show how this works
mathematically we need to do some
geometry because what we know from
physics and we do this all the time as
mathematicians we borrow from laws of
physics we know that the light coming in
the angle here and this is an angle with
the tangent to the parabola right so we
draw the gradient of the parabola there
put its tangent in we know the angle
there is the angle there because it
comes in and reflects at the same angle
it might not look like it on my diagram
this is a sketch
so what we need to do or we need to show
mathematically is that this angle here
and this angle are the same because if
we can show that if we can show the
angle coming in the L coming out based
on going from
a general Point always to here
that would prove from a mathematical
standpoint that everything is going to
be focused at this point that same Theta
applies yes exactly exactly so so the
angle will change this Theta will be
different to the Theta up here
but the key thing is in both situations
so that's called that one Theta one and
let's call this one beta2 so in both
situations we know it has to come in and
go out at the same angle that's just
that's the law of physics we have to
follow but the key thing is it's coming
in at a certain angle bouncing out at
the same one going to the focus our
amplifier this one comes in at a
different angle bounces out at the same
different angle but again it ends up at
the same point and if I had another one
here it would come in bounce out every
time no matter what angle it comes in at
it goes out at the same one but always
into the same point
is this only for beams that are coming
in at a straight line this is only beams
that come in horizontally yes so it is
just for horizontal beams coming in now
of course there's going to be some error
there's some you know uh I don't know
what to call it noise in some of these
signals but this is the sort of theory
behind the parabolic shape it's only the
parabola that will focus to this point
and this is what we're going to show and
if your Target's very far away like a
star or something in space for all
intents and purposes they all are coming
in at the same straight line exactly
yeah yes so this is it also is used in
telescopes exactly for that because
Stars they're so far away you need to
amplify the light that's coming in so
you have to focus it all into the same
point so you use again parabolic mirrors
to do that so the way we do this is
going to be using vectors we want to
describe our positions so this is the
focus our Point P we won't be able to
describe these with vectors and
construct an equation to argue why these
two angles are the same so to start with
we're going to assume they're not the
same we're going to work out this one so
let's call this Theta 2 hat and this one
D2 just to be clear but we're going to
end up showing the Theta 2 hat is Theta
2 where specifically one of them is the
horizontal coming in and one of them is
going to the focus and the key aspect to
this is remember I introduced this
parameter T which meant there was
nothing special about the point I picked
because as I vary T the whole problem
just moves around so that's where we get
the generality and that's why we are
ultimately showing how these things work
first of all we need to know the tangent
to the curve up here we've actually have
an equation we know that y squared is
equal to 4ax we want to know the
gradient of P so the gradient at that
point is found by differentiating our
function d y by DX so we know the
coordinates of p as well don't we we
know that's a t squared and Y is 280. so
we have to do implicit differentiation
which tells us 2y Dy by the x equals 4A
so that's just differentiating both
sides with respect to X and then we
rearrange that so that tells us that d y
by the x is for a over 2y we want to
know it at this point where this is X
and this is y so we sum in that y value
into here so we can say the gradient d y
by the X at the point p is 4A over 2
times the Y value there which is 2 a t
four a over four a t it's 1 over t
so the first thing to check is is that
sensible as I change T my gradient here
changes so this is our gradient at this
point now as I decrease T I'm moving
closer and becomes steeper right here
it's vertical
so when T is not I've got one over
naught that's tending to Infinity which
is a vertical gradient so we see that
the gradient actually gets steeper as we
move in this way and it's going to get
flatter as I move out here so it does
make sense that it would come out like
this but it's good that t is in there
because we want this to be general for
any point in the diagram so now we've
got the gradient at the point p
we now want to work out well what is
this direction Vector here between this
line and this so we're trying to get
Theta 2. so we want the vector from P to
our Focus which is a0 so a vector
between those two points is just the
vector here minus the value here doesn't
matter whether we're going out or in we
just need something in that direction so
the vector from P to that point is
simply just P minus that so that's P
subtract that so that Vector will be
let's call it l so we can say l is going
to be the x value a t squared minus a
that one minus that one and then that y
value minus that one so this is a vector
X component y component which describes
this direction here now we need a vector
to describe the direction of our tangent
so let's call that t so the tangent
Vector T we know d y by the x is 1 over
t
this is the change in y over the change
in X so this tells you that every time x
changes by T Y changes by 1. that's what
a gradient means basically so if we put
every time x changes by T Y changes by
one so our tangent Vector is given by
this T and one corresponds to this
particular gradient up here so what
we've now got is we know the direction
here and we know the direction here as
vectors so if we take the dot product of
those two vectors
gives us the angle
okay I'm just looking you're knotting
like okay if you say so Tom okay so
let's do that so if we do l dot t
then by definition the dot product is
the length of your first Vector times
the length of your second Vector times
COS of the angle between them so that
will be Theta 2 because these are our
two vectors angle between them there
it's Theta two it could of course be the
same one up here but with doesn't matter
for our purposes it's the same angle
right so when you sub these in
right so l dot T is
size of L so when you work out the size
of a vector you square each term add
them together and then square root so
the size of L is this first one squared
a t squared minus a squared plus second
one squared at four a squared t squared
so that is the size of L size of t a bit
easier thankfully it's the square root
of the first one squared plus the second
one squared and then we've got cos Theta
2. now of course we can do the dot
product we've got Vector so you do the
first components multiplied together
added to the second two multiplied
together
so that tells us that one times that one
so a t cubed minus a t plus that one
times that one plus two a t equals the
two square roots times cos Theta two
because what we want is cos Theta 2. so
if I rearrange cos Theta 2 is equal to
this thing we've got an minus 80 plus
280 so that gives me an a t cubed plus a
t on the top and then we've got these
things on the bottom now I'm going to
simplify it a little bit up here so if
we expand out the square a squared t to
the four minus two lots of the Cross
terms so minus 2 a squared t squared
plus a squared and then plus four a
squared t squared so we've got minus two
lots of it plus four lots of it so that
becomes a plus two so we've got a
squared brackets t to the four
plus 2 t squared plus 1.
in that first bracket
and then we've got second bracket t
squared plus one
now this
in here
this is t squared plus 1 squared
expand that out G is the fourth plus two
cross terms plus one so that's that
so you've got an A squared times
something else squared we lose the
square root so what we finally end up
with
cos Theta 2 is we've got an A factor
here as well an A T Factor at the top
80 times t squared plus 1 divided by
square root of this so it gives us a
times t squared plus one times the
square root t squared plus one I know
everything cancels which is lovely
cancels cancels cancels cancels and
we're left with t over the square root
of t squared plus one so we have a
formula for cause of theta 2 this angle
what we now need to show is that we get
the same formula for these two hat and
then we figured it out okay yeah another
piece of paper
so to work out cause of dt2 hat here
same approach let's figure out the
vectors coming in so we've got T is one
vector and the other one is a horizontal
Vector here H and we want the angle
between the two of them so we want the
dot product between T and H so we know
what T is we figured that one out to be
T1
H is a horizontal Vector so that means X
changes and Y doesn't so it's just one
zero it's your basis Vector so when we
take the dot product
T dot h is equal to that one times that
one t plus 1 times 0.
is uh zero add them together that is
then equal to the size of T times the
size of H times COS of the angle between
them which is that one these two have so
so we've got T is equal to the size of
this
square root of one plus t squared size
of H well that's size one times COS of
beta 2 half so we rearrange and say so
COS of theta 2 hat is T over square root
one plus t squared but what did we get
COS of e to two was T over the square
root of one plus t squared so that
allows us to conclude this is the same
it's COS of theta 2 so we can take our
COS of both sides so in other words
Theta 2 is Theta 2 hat which is exactly
what we wanted so rather than just
taking my word for the terrible sketch
we've been able to show mathematically
using vectors using geometry the angle
coming in is the same as the angle going
out where we're coming in horizontal and
we always bounce to the focus because
there was nothing special about the
point P I could just change the value of
T and go here the whole working out
works so we're actually showing that any
horizontal Ray coming in and hitting our
parabolic mirror will always go to that
central point because these two angles
are always the same and light reflection
or sound wave reflection means the angle
a needs to be the angle out so that's
how parabolic mirrors work lovely this
episode of number five was brought to
you by Jane Street a research based
trading firm with officers all across
the globe go to their website and learn
about the jobs and internships they have
on offer
if you're good with numbers or computers
this could be the start of something
very special
but check here they also have fantastic
programs previewing the sort of stuff
they do two current opportunities are
these insight and the wise programs
they're targeted at opportunities for
women transgender and gender expansive
people there are lectures games mock
trading sessions all sorts of hijinks
get your applications in now no matter
who you are Jane Street have got
something of interest to you go to their
website see what's available I'll put a
link in the video description
foreign
[Music]